let's try something normal let's go with
the normal stuff okay um let's try a
king's indian Kings Indian attack if you
do this setup for black it's called
defense for white we label that attack
so what will I be looking to do well I'm
not so sure yet i might want to shift
gears i might want to strike with c4 if
i'm looking to attack i'll look to play
ipod up to you for this is a pretty
Universal set up we have here King side
fiend kettle castle pawn up to deets d3
to prevent this efore advance so now I
need to do something I can't let these
ponds just sit here happily they have to
be hit so how will that happen well I
could do this I think without any
support I think I could still play this
because tactically it's alright if you
for take stakes if the night is
recapturing I follow up with Knight
takes pawn if Knight takes f I could do
Knight takes Knight Knight takes Queen I
do Knight takes Queen from here if the
night grabs upon I can also grab a pond
I think everything is going to work out
quite alright so let's go for it let's
go for it efore right away right away if
the structure changes in this way with
d4 well I'm going to look to get this
pot up to f4 although I might want to do
something like first c3 ok
have any thing better all right that
kind of scares me kind of scares me each
three just pick up the bishop pair hmm
I'd like to be able to play this move
just a box out this night not give them
the d4 square but this pin has me a bit
concerned oh I just play h3 Bishop takes
Queen takes Knight d4 queen here and
then I could kick them away each three
Bishop back I'm still needing to do
something about this pond let's let's
ask a question first is the bishop going
to be a pest you going to keep me in a
pin in other words yes he is he does not
want to let that go clean here just gets
hit with 94 no thanks rook e is
available I think that's what I would
want to do
all right yeah I wanted I wanted to
insert this first just so that I'm a
single move away from breaking this pin
I want to at least get it to that point
h3 kick them back and then it's
immediately kicked not not where it's
still on each two and the bishops here
because then there might be if i do h3
there could be Bishop takes Knight and
that could somehow work in blacks favor
I want to bring it to that point or
again I'm just a single move away from
breaking the pin but not yet committing
this has me worried I'm worried here
because if I do this there's probably
some sacrifice so I think I could what
could I do Bishop here might be a
possibility now let me make sure this
night doesn't jump in here yeah lets
rule that out lets rule it out now at
least I could get my queen here I don't
have to worry about 94 stuff now I want
to keep in mind i want to be in a
position where if Bishop here is played
I could play Knight h4 so maybe on
second thought this idea of Queen to e2
is something I shouldn't be doing not
actually it's still okay queen here is
okay yeah that's fine let's get off of
this I need some more development where
does my night want to go maybe he wants
to go on f1 for some reason I was
thinking after Bishop here I couldn't do
night here I was thinking only my queen
and rook we're defending e4 but that's
not the case not the case Bishop here
night here my bishop is there to defend
so that's how it would be reacting if
Bishop g6 what more is my opponent going
to do probably moving this Bishop is a
good ideas otherwise you're not
releasing this is energy that's built up
on the D file in the meantime I think
just to complete my development I'm
going to be playing Bishop out to g5 and
maybe I do have some thoughts of not
just looking to room the kingside
structure but more long term show that
this Bishop is maybe a dead piece okay
my opponent is ruling that out
with a within h7 f7f 6 and e5 structure
in this Bishop caught in this sector of
the board you could turn out to be a
dead piece with a g4 and e4 structure on
the white side okay so night or bishop
probably my night my night working so is
this played was this a dual purpose move
to keep my bishop out and be in a spot
to have Bishop g6 and then if night h4
Bishop back I don't think whoa whoa whoa
whoa that is one scary move that is
definitely a scary move if I do this is
my opponent going to capture
Wow
push Knight takes pawn takes Queen takes
oh man night here's what I would like to
do I wasn't even thinking my opponent
would do that well then why why wouldn't
I be thinking that shame on me I'm gonna
do that shame on me if my opponent
doesn't take I get my night into this
square although I can't do that right
away am I talking about Bishop here I
have to do something up this pun why
wasn't I thinking I was completely
oblivious to this idea and why should i
have been warped castle on opposite side
so it makes sense to want to launch
these ponds forward and I should really
keep my pawns as close to my king but
I'm seeing a reason to maybe going for
this alright so first order of business
is to get out of this pin I can't get
out of the pen so easily though let's do
this first this should be defendable
these two pieces aren't doing anything
and I'm looking to play night here and
now i'm pretty sure this is going to be
defendable if i could establish a night
right here i'm still not out of the pin
by the way this we're both under minute
Bishop h5 Bishop h5 I jumped my knight
in here and everything is okay but wait
a second it just take this very valuable
LightSquared bishop let's get rid of him
and do my favorite move my favorite move
offer Queen trade
we trade I was thinking about King h2
bishop age three but that's just hope
Jess I would just be hoping for stuff
actually by force the Queen's have to
come off if the Queen went away I could
play Queen here so not I'm up a piece if
I'd played here right away and then just
get the door slammed on me see this come
with this one I'm not sure how much it
matters i want to do this so there's no
tricky tactics and that's following me
it's definitely bothering me no he's not
now I now I've light squares I have like
light square control Joe my bishop in
there is that not gonna bother me I
don't think so play King age too I think
I have everything covered how much time
very little for both of us I was also on
f6 that's why I went there I'm not sure
I guess I want to try and get in this c4
c5 okay that bishops dead maybe a skewer
if captures let's just get that tricky
night out there okay he was in pre move
mode no time oh man ok good game
sandwich ham let's back up oh my
goodness see the mental blunders i was
making not specific moves but general
ideas why wasn't i considering g5 this
move is the first one that strikes me as
odd Queen here our Bishop 2d6
obstructing the Queen so what's
something better I think something
that's maybe more tame with Bishop to e7
Bishop c5 i'm pretty sure runs into a
knight captures typical sacrifice in the
center with dee dee for to follow right
Bishop c5 there would be Knight takes
Knight takes with D for to follow you
get the piece back Bishop e2 I think is
going to be a little bit better I wonder
also about this idea of not declaring
your dark square Bishop just yet I
wonder if you could play Bishop g4 with
Queen to d7 and think about queenside
castling here's one on one way to look
at this position with white playing d3
you can be saying to yourself as black
that it's either going to be e4 or c4
that's used to strike at the center and
with that in mind you can anticipate
well you could be capturing those ponds
as a result and then what's what's
changing file wise the d file and in
anticipation of that there might be some
sense therefore with Queen side castling
i think in situations okay it's most
common where you Castle kingside and
chest but if there's situations where
you're able to castle and you're able to
Castle Queen side and automatically get
your King safe and have your rook active
on an open file namely the D file that's
something to look into so I wonder a
little bit in other words about this
idea of bringing the light square Bishop
out and then following up with Queen to
d7 but I do have some worry in that of
Bishop g4 being met with first h3 does
the bishop really want to be sectioned
off on this side of the board I'm not so
sure in any event I think that's
something to look into that idea of a
queen side castle which is what you
ended up doing but the other thing is to
keep the bishop out of the way along
this d file he ended up just being stuck
on d6 for pretty much the whole game
until her it was just me being up a
piece so I think maybe Bishop to e7 is a
little bit better keeping a much closer
I the other way to look at it is that
you're obstructing your Queens view of
this point right here which is the one
point I'm really going to be putting
pressure on soon enough in this case I
went with you four but there could you
can also be seeing c4 with Knight c3 to
follow ok you didn't go with that
capture but there were tactical shots
with 95 h3 rookie one now the Queen
bumps up so you did go forward with that
and you do go with Queen's Head castle
age 6 I was completely blind to this
advance right here can you hear that
sleet in the background it's coming down
pretty good here p a crazy PA weather
anyhow all right here comes g5 this
seems um it's definitely a little bit
scary here I wonder if you could still
just back up and then look to play h5 I
don't know that I'm any better it's hard
it's hard to imagine that I would be any
better in this position with having
moved so many ponds in front of my king
you having this pond break with h5 in
soon enough an open H file and it
wouldn't then come at the cost of a
piece maybe being a bit more patient
with Bishop g6 is okay somehow i see
this is still being defendable with a
few minor pieces around these two pieces
your your other you have this one very
active minor piece but when you look at
these two takes a while from to get
working and I have this idea of a night
maybe jumping into this square so I
don't know if the if the sacrifice is a
sound one it seems like it would be
defendable but maybe just a calm retreat
with h5 to follow and I'm in some
trouble here you have the safer King
maybe just back up you're on this pond I
was thinking for a moment I could play
night f12 g3 but it's not there in time
bishop g6 I have to do something with
this the queen is not a good leader in
defending this pond that's a I'm
struggling to do something good I
believe after Bishop g6 but we went in
for that and as soon as i got that light
square Bishop there's really not much he
could be doing he's still kind of debt
to the game this night it's just not
it's just not working out with without
the Queen's on the board and then time
scrambles alrighty um okay good game
sandwich ham I mean